I'm a bookie with me you bet on credit
and this business model works assuming
you get paid sometimes up I have to
improvise
this time of year funds are low and high
school Hey
are you friends with my mom I look at
him to be honest with you I have no idea
if I told your mom that is gonna watch
it I play baseball I got a game if you
want to come I see it nobody else did
you're gonna take bets on kids games
and tomorrow Eagle Spartan to in Eagles
easy I saw it on that mark
big spot I had a birthday party last
night he's asleep over and half the
Berenstain was there I hear you're
taking bets on kids games let's hold you
have three except for this guy
Smitty you got a kid boys no no kid oh
that's great that's great
[Music]
I was a pitcher I can give you some
pointers seriously
first batter you face I want you to
throw it out that's why you wear helmets
these are a little out of control Kukoc
me through what about this is your fault
natives got Restless I want you stop
gambling on the boys baseball games
[Music]
was all knowledge so great it used to
stop my father people in town act like
savages
everything else in my life
you have that kid throw the game
whoa God kids right be doing practicing
sitting on the bench you know what you
got in there yes shut him up
you